yellow fever has been the scourge of
africa since the 15th century according
to oral accounts of early epidemics
this virus disease is transmitted by
mosquitoes
man other primates and some mammals are
the reservoir
historically yellow fever has remained
endemic in the rain forest zone
favorable to its maintenance cycle
between the latitudes of 15 degrees
north and 15 degrees south
yet as of now this zone is still
expanding south into arid habitats
in southern sudan the nuba mountains are
home to a population which despite its
geographic and social isolation has been
repeatedly visited by the virus since
1934
the largest ever epidemic occurred in
1940 with twenty thousand cases reported
and a mortality of up to twenty percent
the disease became endemic and kept
creeping south
at the naval medical research unit 3 in
cairo egypt scientists from the
rockefeller foundation were actively
engaged in the study of west nile and
other arbor viruses
it was thus decided to undertake a
reconnaissance in southern sudan the
objective was twofold
determine if there had been yellow fever
transmission subsequent to 1940
and then find out if the galago a
primate common in tropical africa
plays a role as a reservoir south of the
recognized endemic zone
the opportunity for such investigation
was provided by dr mansour professor of
microbiology at the school of medicine
in khartoum
and the sudan veterinary services
they were undertaking the extermination
of all warm-blooded animals in an
attempt to eradicate the sitsi fly south
of the bar al-arab by eliminating the
source of blood meals
the fly which transmits triponosomiasis
also known as sleeping sickness
had been responsible for a high
mortality in cattle
as a result whole populations of nilotic
indigenous people fled southern sudan
by interrupting the breeding cycle it
was hoped that people would return to
the area and raise cattle
a source of beef which could be exported
via khartoum and port sudan
the namuru team went along with the
veterinarian teams in charge of
eliminating wild animals and conversed
the area from elobed to gauguial making
blood collections from humans and
various species of primates
eleven villages were visited
as the dc progresses up the nile a
golden mosaic of canyons and twisted
earth unfolds
this is the nubian desert a mystical
palette of okras and shadows transfixed
by the abysmal gorge of the river
the perpetuity of these arid horizons
seems to float in a reddish haze of
light heat and dust
much of this is now under the waters of
lake nasser
because the s1 dam was built in the
sixties
the city of khartoum was built in 1821
by the egyptian army
its name means elephant trunk
because here the blue nile concludes its
tumultuous descent from the highlands of
ethiopia and meets in a sweeping curve
the white nile flowing from uganda
adjacent to the desert are the irrigated
farms of the people who live on the
banks of the nile
the confluence takes place under the
bridge linking khartoum to the
industrial hub of amderman
the color contrast is noteworthy
these ancient falucas are still the main
mean of transport along and across the
river
lord kitchener relieved the british
forces led by gordon and besieged in
khartoum for ten months by the mahdi
chinese gordon so nicknamed because of
his heroic crimean campaigns
remained defiant until the final assault
and was killed
both statues were removed when sudan
gained its independence
the tomb of the mahdi is on the other
side of the river in amderman
it is a holy place of pilgrimage for the
muslim sudanese
the blue coppola is topped by the muslim
crescent penetrated by a spear
which is the emblem of the mahdi himself
in front of the laboratory equipment is
loaded onto a jeep
it is loaned by the u s map service
they are busy mapping the continent of
africa from cape to cairo in preparation
for the first space flight around the
world
wherever the british arrived they
developed the railway network and such
was the case for sudan
khartoum became the hub and a transport
point to the red sea and port sudan
two other spurs went respectively north
to darfur and south to cordovan and
elobed
all heavy material must be hoisted on a
flatbed
this electrolux refrigerator is operated
with kerosene and will be indispensable
for storage of field collected specimens
the microbiology department involved in
tropical disease research has utilized
the railroad system for transporting a
laboratory car to various parts of sedan
personal effects and more fragile
equipment are loaded in this car which
will be pooled at the end of the railway
the tarpoolin will provide shelter when
specimens are being brought from the
bush
this magnificent steam locomotive will
reach lobed at the top speed of 35 miles
an hour and there will be only a few
places to fill up the water tank
the engineers are putting the last
nurturing touches of oil
recommendations are made
everything is checked to ensure a safe
voyage
the 250 mile train journey ends at ello
bead in central sudan
this is a road and caravan junction on
the migration paths from west africa
this is also the end of the railroad and
from there the 2 000 mile inland trek to
the nuba mountains will be on a dirt and
sand road too hard or too soft for
driving comfort
short grass savannah thorny bush's
akashas are the main features of the
cordovan province
as the train stops to take on water the
steam is converted to hot water for tea
this truck taking an audacious turn is
heavily loaded with equipment and
personal baggage from the laboratory car
it also carries the field assistance
kasha is the first nuba village to be
reached its round huts gripping the
flanks of a volcanic outcrop are typical
such hillocks cover approximately 3 000
square miles and range from 300 to 3600
feet in height
women are returning to the village
carrying water collected from far away
in large gourds
their elongated silhouettes are
astonishingly regal and beautiful
the nuba people have been victims of
arab slave traders for centuries and
have learned how to protect themselves
in these tiny villages tucked among
forbidding cliffs and peaks
water comes from springs and percolation
pockets
some tribes have remained isolated from
each other with little or no social
interaction
they speak close to a hundred different
dialects
the nuba are essentially farmers they
are animists and worship their cattle
which they believe harbor the ghost of
their ancestor
therefore
it will be rarely sacrificed for food
these are some of the boys from whom it
would be desirable to obtain a blood
sample to determine whether they have
antibodies to yellow fever which would
reflect transmission since 1940.
to befriend the population is a task
greatly facilitated by the presence of
dr mansour who is sudanese and speaks
the language
these young warriors have sophisticated
mohawks which accentuate the beauty of
their profiles
they often wear on their chest a leather
pouch which contains a few verses of the
quran
this is for good luck
every man carries a spear which is used
mostly for cultivating but also for
hunting
both men and women undergo painful
scarifications for cosmetic purposes
it is also a test of courage and
stoicism for the young adult
skin incisions are made with sharp
knives thorns or pieces of glass rubbed
with dirt
these wounds are left to fester
producing the raised scar known as
keloids
in women
elaborate patterns are added for each
major life event such as puberty
marriage and the birth of children
in talody word is passed on to the chief
without whom nothing could be
accomplished
a suitable explanation must be provided
in order to bleed the population
dr taylor is an old hand at yellow fever
having been the director of the yellow
fever laboratory in rio de janeiro
and ultimately at the rockefeller
institute in new york
he is an expert at coercing smiles from
these young children
the operation is supervised with great
interest
four children 12 and 13 years old tested
positive in the foothills of the nuba
mountains
this demonstrated that yellow fever
transmission had occurred after 1940.
this little primate with globulous eyes
and long fingers is a galago or bush
baby it is nocturnal and sleeps during
the day in tree hollows
local boys will capture them at night by
harassing them in the trees where they
are feeding
the hussar monkey is so named after his
red coat and because he marches in open
spaces with military precision
he is one of the less common primates of
tropical africa
the bagara or cattlemen are nomadic
descendants of 14th century bedouin
invaders
a balboa tree breaks the monotony of
their journey
it is home to many animals and people
store water inside its trunk
the pulp of its fruit is commonly used
to treat diarrhea
the bagara migrate from western africa
during the dry season
they congregate around the depressions
called wadi where water accumulates all
year round
what role these people play in transport
of yellow fever is unknown
this large herd of cattle has traveled
nearly one thousand miles and it
represents many breeds
the black zebu from india with a typical
hump has large round white horns
the ankole watusi is a mix of zebu and a
local african breed
its large extended horns are reminiscent
of the texas longhorn
this is the home of the dinka who
belonged to the river lake nylots the
largest ethnic group in southern sudan
tending goats sheep and cattle is their
primary activity
in this area water is extracted from 15
to 20 feet deep wells
and transported for storage into large
troughs
branches and leaves are used as a filter
mosquito larvae can be found on the
surface
there was no time to investigate these
mosquitoes which are important vectors
of jungle yellow fever
for the bagara the ox is a common means
of transportation and replaces the horse
which would not survive in this ecology
because of the sitsi fly transmitted
diseases
again everyone carries a spear for
protection from lions
but also from cattle raiders and other
possible rogues
the procession meanders in the high
savanna interspersed with a cautious
these guinea fowl are scampering when
the truck appears
this is probably the most common animal
of the area and it provides the meat
that could not be carried on the trip
this cercopathicus atheist is a common
resident of the jungle a blood sample
will be obtained during its necropsy
it is possible to draw about 60
milliliters from the heart of
warm-blooded animals up to two hours
after death
specimens collected in the first 15 days
of this investigation were driven to wa
on ice for air shipment to cartoon and
proper storage until the return to egypt
a total of 110 primates were collected
70 to 80 percent of the grivet and
ninety percent of the baboons had
antibody to yellow fever
the number of positive galagos in red
hussar was below six percent regardless
of the area
therefore these two primates were not a
significant virus reservoir
the bar-el arab is very low because of
the lateness of the dry season but it
still requires a ferry to reach the
mayan mission
it is the most southern point of this
reconnaissance
here the rainfall can reach 40 inches as
compared to 13 in northern sudan
lakes waterholes and marshes abound
the curiosity of the dinka people does
not abate as the jeep makes its way to
the mission
our knowledge about the role played by
wild birds in circulating many viruses
transmitted by mosquitoes and ticks has
accumulated for 50 years since the
inception of the rockefeller program
here are ibis stilts and egrets feeding
together egrets of course are involved
in the japanese bee west nile virus
complex scenario
which was to unfold in egypt and later
on was to be recognized in
asia the whalehead stork also known as
shoebill stork has a melancholic pause
for the photographer
its beauty is debatable
it possesses an enormous bill with a
hook to dig for lungfish frogs and other
delicacies
two crested cranes are parading their
colorful elegance
they are considered sacred and can only
belong to kings
these giraffes have escaped the
veterinary hunters
this
is baboon country
these flooded areas constitute the sued
from which the name sudan comes from
it is a band 100 miles long
it becomes inundated during the rainy
season as the water flows from lake
victoria and into the nile becoming a
regular river
it will subsequently reach the
mediterranean
four thousand miles further north
thompson gazelles appear at sunset
here is the residue of inundated
marshlands
it's a mecca for all kinds of water
birds who spend a good deal of their
life feeding on the fish and other life
essential to their survival
when the animals are killed their skin
is removed saturated with insecticides
and put on a frame to attract the sitzi
flies
they will die upon feeding on this
poison
this is another strategy to break the
trypanosome cycle of transmission
behind these dinka are termite mounds
the material extracted from these mounds
becomes very adhesive when wet and can
be used to build houses
two marabou storks contemplate their
domain
they have a pompous gate which gave them
the nickname of adjutant storks
their formidable bill makes them a
successful and rarely challenged
scavenger
even for these vultures
which abound in the region
a new village is being established
the building of these houses is
undertaken by men only
some are loosening the dirt from
termites mounds
others are mixing it with sand in a
water pit
the chief is supervising a very
well-dressed dinka wears three strings
of beads
otherwise these people well adapted to
the hot climate of sedan wear no clothes
this social affair is carried at a
leisurely pace
a dragon lizard is worried by all this
effervescence he might lose his abode
the huts have a roof made of straw it is
supported by a frame to which the clay
is applied in long and consistent
strokes
this is a slow process to ensure that
all the nooks and crannies are filled
when the appropriate thickness of coat
has been achieved a process of rubbing
and smoothing takes place
at the end
the wall will have the blue shine of a
ceramic glaze
but
even in these houses people are exposed
to mosquito bites during the rainy
season
the journey ends in war from which the
specimens will be dispatched to khartoum
for storage
neutralization tests were performed on
660
human cera
they showed that the percentage of
yellow fever positive samples was higher
in the south in the bar el arab area
in the age group of 15 years and over
the reactors were 80 percent and 30
percent respectively
the occurrence of positive children and
young primates proved that since 1940
yellow fever had become endemic in
southern sudan
the seasonal shifting of cattle and
people combined with roaming bands of
griffith monkeys provided all the
necessary ingredients for virus
reintroduction and maintenance of the
transmission cycle
it is now time to return to ella bead
with a last glimpse of the wildlife of
tropical southern sudan
in wa this dc3 is the workhorse for
transport in more remote areas it will
bring the cargo of precious specimens to
khartoum
there is a last look at khartoum in its
magical robe of sands
and at the blue nile which separates the
tropical areas of southern sudan from
the north
and upper egypt
you